okay
thank you
oh yeah
see
uh
um
nice
okay
mr
thank you
i'm gonna run out
thank you
love it
um
uh
oh yeah
uh
all right
come on
okay
my god
so
all right
um
music
hey
okay
um
okay
uh
smart
one
you
now
so
seconds
thank you
yes
uh
so
uh
then
okay
oh
straight up
sleep
oh
all right
[Music]
oh
your delays
yes
thank you
there's
shopping
uh
okay
hmm
foreign
oh
[Music]
yes
i don't know
uh
foreign
yeah okay
you
okay
so
okay
okay
uh
okay
okay
it is
uh
my check one two might check one two
give me a thumbs up if everything is
good my check one two
my check one two thank you
uh
questions
president
thank you
i don't thank you
i love you
okay
me
yes
give me this
yep
uh
good evening before i
turn to uh today's meetings
i want to say a short word about our
ongoing fight against coven 19
at home we've made enormous progress in
the united states
much of the country is returning to
normal
and our economic growth is leading the
world and the number of cases and deaths
are dropping dramatically but there's
still
too many lives being lost we're still
averaging the last seven days
loss of 370 deaths per day
370 deaths that's significantly lower
than at the peak of this crisis
but it's still a real tragedy we're
approaching a sad milestone
almost 600 000 lost
lives because of covert 19 in america
my heart goes out to all those who've
lost a loved one
i know that black hole that
seems to consume you that fills up your
chest
when you lose someone's close to you
that you adored
that's why i continue to say to america
if you've not been vaccinated
get vaccinated get vaccinated as soon as
possible
we have plenty vaccinations plenty of
sites
we have more work to do to beat this
virus
and now is not the time to let our guard
down
so please please get vaccinated as soon
as possible
we've had enough pain enough pain
folks i know uh it's uh
after 9 30 brussels time 9 30 p.m and
i'm still at nato
you're all excited about that i know
but i've had a chance to meet with
several leaders
recently and i've had calls with others
it's been an incredibly productive day
here
i just finished meeting with president
erdogan of turkey
we had a positive and productive meeting
much of it
one-on-one we had detailed discussions
about how to proceed
on a number of a number of issues
[Music]
our two countries have big agendas
our teams are going to continue our
discussions and i'm confident
we'll make real progress with turkey and
the united states
but now i want to thank secretary
general stoltenberg for leading
a very successful nato summit today
i had the honor of leading off the
discussion
today among the 30 nations
and i pointed out that we're facing a
once in a century
global health crisis at the same time
the democratic values
that undergird our alliance are under
increasing pressure
both internally and externally
russia and china are both seeking to
drive a wedge in our
transatlantic solidarity we're seeing an
increase in malicious cyber activity
but our alliance is a strong foundation
on which we can our collective security
and our shared prosperity
can continue to be built and i made a
point to make
clear that the u.s commitment to article
5
the nato treaty is rock solid
and unshakable it's a sacred commitment
nato nato stands together
that's how we met every other threat in
the past
it's our greatest strength as we meet
our challenges of the future and there
are many
and everyone everyone in that room today
understood the shared appreciation
quite frankly that america is back
we talked about russia's aggressive acts
that pose a threat to nato
and our collective security that's why i
met with the bucharest nine
the eastern flank allies in advance of
this summit
and today also met with the leaders of
the three baltic states estonia latvian
lithuania
i shared with our allies that i'll
convey to pres what i'll convey to
president putin
but i'm not looking for conflict with
russia but that we will respond if
russia continues its harmful activities
and we will not fail to defend the
transatlantic alliance
or stand up for democratic values
as allies we also affirmed our continued
support
for the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine
we agreed to keep consulting closely on
nuclear deterrence
arms control and strategic stability
and there was a strong consensus in the
room among the leaders
in that meeting on afghanistan
our troops are coming home we agreed
that our diplomatic economic and
humanitarian commitment
to the afghan people and our support for
the afghan national defense and security
forces
will endure and i welcomed
our allies and partners to recognize
that counter-terrorism
the counter-terrorism efforts must
continue to ensure that
afghanistan never again becomes a gate a
safe haven
for attacks on our countries even as we
take on terrorist networks in the middle
east
and africa and i'm deeply gratified
that as an alliance we adopted a
far-reaching plan to make sure
nato can meet the challenges that we
face today
and in the future not yesterday
the nato 2030 agenda
and that we agreed to fully resource
that agenda
the last time nato put together a
strategic plan was back in 2010
when russia was considered a partner and
china wasn't even mentioned
we talked about the long-term systemic
challenges that china's activities pose
to our collective security today we
agreed to do more to enhance the
resilience of our
critical infrastructures around the
world including trusted
telecommunications providers
supply chains and energy networks
we agreed to enhance our cooperation
with our democratic partners in the
indo-pacific
to meet challenges that exist there we
also endorsed a new cyber defense policy
nato's first in the past seven years
to improve the collective ability to
defend against counter threats
from state and non-state actors against
our networks and our critical
infrastructure
when we adopted a climate security
action plan
which several years ago people thought
we would never would do
for reducing emissions from nato
installations and adapting to the
security risks
of climate change while keeping us sharp
very very sharp on our ability to deter
and defend against threats
and finally we agreed that among the
most important
shared missions is renewing and
strengthening
the resilience of our democracies
i pointed out we have to prove to the
world and to our own people
that democracy can still prevail against
the challenges of our time
and deliver for the needs of our people
we have to root out corruption that
siphons off our strength
guard against those who would stoke
hatred
and division for political gain as phony
populism
invest in strengthening the institutions
that underpin
and safeguard our cherished democratic
values as well as protecting the free
press
and independent judiciaries all of those
are on the agenda
that's how we'll prove the democracy and
that our alliance
can still prevail against the challenges
of our time
and deliver for the needs and the needs
of our people
this is going to be looked at 25 years
from now as whether or not we stepped up
to the
challenge because there's a lot of
a lot of autocracies that are counting
on
them being able to move more rapidly and
successfully
in an ever complicated world than
democracies can
we all conclude we're going to prove
them wrong
and now i'm happy to take some questions
cecilia vega of abc
thank you so much sir good evening um
you mentioned your sit down with
vladimir putin
and and russian aggression that came up
in your conversations today i'd like to
ask you two questions if i may on that
front
um is it your sense walking into this
meeting that americans back home
shouldn't expect much in terms of an
outcome
could you provide some specifics on what
a successful meeting would look like
to you are there going to be specific
concessions you want putin to make
then i'll just give you my my follow-up
right now you've met vladimir putin
before
what have you learned about him that
informs how you approach
this sit down with him and what's your
mindset walking into a meeting
with a former kgb agent who you've said
has no soul
i'll tell you all that when it's over
look
i've been doing this a long time the
last thing
anyone would do is negotiate in front of
the world press
as to how he's going to approach a
critical meeting
with another adversary and or
someone who could be an adversary it's
the last thing i'm going to do
but i will tell you this i'm going to
make clear
to president putin that
there are areas where we can't cooperate
if he chooses
and if he chooses not to cooperate
and acts in a way that he has in the
past
relative to cyber security and some
other
activities then we will respond
we are responding kind there need not be
we should decide
where it's in our mutual interest in the
interest of the world to cooperate
and see if we can do that and the areas
where we don't agree
make it clear what the red lines are
i have met with him he's bright
he's tough and uh i have found that uh
he is a uh as they say when he used to
play ball a worthy adversary
but the fact is that uh i will be happy
to talk with you when it's over
not before about what the discussion
will entail
uh nancy corder cbs
thank you mr president i also have two
questions about vladimir putin the first
is have any of the world leaders you've
met with this week expressed concern
that by meeting with
president putin this early in your
presidency that it'll look like you're
rewarding him
what's your second question the section
the second question is
what it will mean for the u.s russia
relationship
if alexei navali were to die or be
killed in prison
every world leader
here as a member of nato that spoke
today and most of them mentioned it
thanked me for meeting with putin
now every single one
that spoke and i think there were
probably about 10 or 12 that spoke to it
saying they were happy that i did that
that i was going to do that and they
thought it was
thoroughly appropriate that i do and i
had discussions with them
about oh in the open about what they
thought
was important from their perspective and
what they thought was not important
and so the interesting thing is i know
and i'm not being critical of the press
i really mean this
give my word but generically you all
thought was by medium too soon
i haven't found a world leader who
doesn't think it's not soon it's just
just soon enough everyone that i've
spoken to
privately and public it doesn't mean
there aren't some out there
but it's not on it's not likely that a
head of state is going to stand up in
front of 29 other heads of state and say
boy i'm glad you're doing this
in effect so there is a consensus
and they thanked me for being willing to
talk with them about
the meeting and what i was uh
what i intended to do so
i i haven't found any any resultants
there may be someone
but not in open today or in the meetings
probably privately had as well
and uh navalny's
death would be another
indication that russia
has little or no intention abiding by
basic fundamental human rights
it would be a tragedy it would do
nothing
but hurt his relationships
with the rest of the world in my view
and with me uh
jeff zelney cnn
sir good evening thank you um in a
weekend interview vladimir putin
laughed at the suggestion that you had
called him a killer
is that still your belief sir that he is
a killer
and i'll continue the trend if you don't
mind asking a second question do you
believe if he does agree to cooperate
then what kind of a challenge do you
find yourself in how would you ever
trust him
and if ronald reagan said trust but
verify what do you say to vladimir putin
answer the first question
laughing too they actually uh
well look i mean he has made clear that
uh
the answer is i believe he is in the
past
essentially acknowledged that he was
uh there are certain things that he
would do or
did do but look um when i was asked that
question
on air i answered it honestly but it's
not
much of a i i don't think it matters a
whole lot in terms of this next meeting
we're about to have
the second question was
relay
i'd verify first and then trust in other
words everything would have to be
shown to be actually occurring
it's not about you know uh trusting
it's about agreeing you know when we
uh when you write treaties with your
adversaries you don't say i trust you
you say this is what i expect and if you
violate the agreement you made then we
the the quote the treaties off the
agreement's off
and uh i'm hoping that
that president putin concludes that
there is some interest
in terms of his own interest in
changing the perception that the world
has of him
in terms of whether or not he will
engage in
behavior that's more consistent with
what is considered to be appropriate
behavior for head of state
um ann guerin the washington post
thank you mr president uh here at at
this meeting
and earlier at the g7 you've said
several times that america is back at
allies side
but a lot of those allies are themselves
pretty rattled by what happened on
january 6 an attempted
overturning of your election and they
may still be
alarmed by the continued hold that
donald trump has over the republican
party
and the rise of nationalist figures like
him around the world
what do you say to those allies what
have you been saying to them
at these meetings about how the next
president of the united states can keep
any promises you make
what i'm saying is them to them
is watch me
i mean i'm not saying anything quite
frankly i'm just going out
people as i've said before don't doubt
that i mean what i say and they believe
that i
keep my commitments when i say it i'm
not making any promises to anyone that
i don't believe are overwhelmingly
likely to be kept
i think that we're at a moment where
i mean let me put it this way you may
have
had a different view but i think an
awful lot of people thought
that my showing up at the
g7 would not produce any kind of
enthusiasm about american leadership
and about where america was i would
suggest that
it didn't turn out that way i would
suggest that there is
a um
the leaders i'm dealing with in nato and
the g7
are leaders who know our recent history
know generically the character of the
american people
and know where the vast center of the
public stands
not democrat republican but who we are
we're decent honorable nation and i
think that they
have seen things happen
as we have that shocked them and
surprised them that could have happened
but i think they like i do believe the
american people are not going to sustain
that kind of behavior and so
i uh you know i don't want to get into
this these statistics because you know
that whole
phrase of the israelis there's three
kinds of lies lies damn lies and
statistics
but i think it's appropriate to say that
the republican party is vastly
diminished in numbers
the leadership of the republican party
is
fractured and the
trump wing of the party is the bulk of
the party
but it makes up a significant minority
of the american people
and we'll see we'll see
i believe that by
us standing up and saying what we
believe
to be the case not engaging in the
overwhelming hyperbole that gets engaged
in by
so many today that um
we uh i guess that old expression the
proof of
puddings and eating when we said
when i said i was going to deal with
beating the virus
i was going to focus on that and i was
going to get millions of shots in
people's arms it wasn't me i just knew
the american people
i knew the kind of help i'd get from the
defense department from police
departments from
from the hospitals from from retired
docs from
i i just knew and look how rapidly we
moved now we have
a group of people who were everything
from
the political rejection of the notion of
taking a vaccine
to people who are simply afraid of a
needle and everything in between
we have a way to go but i never doubted
that we would be able to
generate the kind of support we got and
get so many
millions of people step up and get
vaccinated
so i i think it is
a shock and surprise that what's
happened
in terms of the consequence of president
trump's phony populism
has has happened and it is disappointing
that so many of my republican colleagues
in the senate who i know
know better have been reluctant to
take on for example an
investigation because they're worried
about being primaried
but at the end of the day we've been
through periods like this in american
history before
where there has been this reluctance to
take a chance on your re-election
because of the nature of your party's
politics at the moment
i think this is passing i don't mean
easily passing
that's why it's so important that i
succeed
in my agenda the agenda whether it's
dealing with the vaccine the economy
infrastructure
it's important that we demonstrate we
can make progress
and continue to make progress and i
think we're going to be able to do that
so
um as i said the proof will be in
where it is you know six months from now
where we are
but i think you're going to see that
there's a
that god willing we're going to be
making progress and there's going to be
a coalescing
of a lot of republicans particularly
younger republicans who
are coming up in the party and uh last
question sebastian smith
of the afp
thank you thank you mr president
uh ukraine wants a clear yes or no
on getting into the nato membership
action plan
so what's your answer and for me a
second part of the same question
uh well now that russia has invaded
parts of ukraine
does that effectively rule out ukraine
ever entering nato
given that being a nato would mean the
u.s and nato having to defend ukrainians
against russia
thank you the second question is the
answer is
no the first question it depends on
whether they meet the criteria
the fact is they still have to clean up
corruption the fact is they have to meet
other criteria
to get into the action plan and so it's
you know
schools out on that question it remains
to be seen
in the meantime we will do all that we
can to
put ukraine in the position to be able
to continue to resist
russian physical aggression and it will
not just depend on me whether or not we
conclude that
that ukraine can become part of nato
will
depend on the alliance and how they vote
but i know for one thing there has to be
a comm they have to convince
and it's not easy i made a speech years
ago to the rada
saying that that ukraine had an
opportunity to do something that's never
occurred in the history of ukraine
actually generate a democratically
elected
and not corrupt
led by oligarchies in any other regions
nation and i pointed out to them when i
made that speech
that they will go down in history as the
founding fathers of ukraine if in fact
they do that
they have more to do but that does not
justify the fact they have more to do
russia taking aggressive action either
in the dumbass or
in on the sea or in
any part of ukraine and we're going to
put ukraine in a position
to be able to maintain their physical
security
thank you all so very much sorry you're
all here so late thank you very much
you